you and i get into a car accident you
know this morning
you are enlightened and so you're like
oh i've got insurance
that could have been worse you walk away
you go you go do three podcast
interviews you have a great day you meet
a bunch of friends all this stuff you
know i'm like
swearing all day freaking chris and one
more thing in the world that what could
go wrong this year and i i get in a
fight with my brother
i don't do the goal thing that i said i
want to do like we both experienced the
same
thing right how we chose to respond and
react to that
we tell ourselves different truth we
tell ourselves the truth that my day got
ruined by a car accident well that's not
that's not really the whole truth the
truth is you had a car accident and that
wasn't your fault but you control
what comes after that
what does the word elevate mean to you
yeah i mean to me elevate just means
taking it to
another level and i think the important
part of that
and and the way i look at it differently
than maybe some others i think when you
talk about success versus achievement
but to me it's like really like to your
potential
not other people's definition not what
other people think you should be doing
but
how do you within you you know raise
your game to another level
from from the potential that lies within
and
you've looked at a framework to go
around that obviously you're a business
owner
multi multinational international
business for multiple years now
into the uh into the twilight of running
a business i think as as many people
would
yeah would have said by this time not
many people have survived
teenage adolescent years so
yeah i i sort of fell into this
framework
by accident so i had actually started a
note to my team
about five years ago every friday it
came out of actually a personal
leadership
event that i went to for a week that was
hugely impactful very focused on
improving your morning things you could
do in the morning kind of think reflect
read something positive right
the reading positive stuff that i wrote
was just way too rainbow and unicorny
for me like it didn't it didn't do it
for me like so i
i had some stories and some quotes and
some stuff that i saved and i just
started writing this note to my team
every friday of 40 and it was it was
something about
we were all remote and it was about
getting better or improvement and
it sort of fell into a formula and i
wasn't sure if people were reading it
but i liked writing it it was a good
habit
and eventually i heard from back from
people that they were they were reading
it they were sharing inside the company
i told some other people around it
eventually i opened it up so people
outside the company could join it and
there were
a couple hundred thousand people within
a few years signed up for it so
what happened was when i went to write a
book our company had really grown we had
sort of tripled during that time period
um i was meeting a lot of interesting
high achievers from all around the world
and
i just did this pattern analysis sort of
came up which was
i tried to write a compilation book
called friday forward ironically which
is the book i just released
but no one would buy it maybe they said
look you're not no one knows you and you
can't write a compilation these stories
are online
but the agent challenged me to like
what's the story behind the story and so
so when i actually started looking at
how had i fundamentally changed my life
in the last three years
what how what how have we grown as a
company we always said we invested in
people holistically
why were these little notes having an
impact on strangers i had never met and
what was common about all these high
achievers that i would run into
like these four things just i mean i had
lists and cry and it just
you know you know punted squares and it
just always came back to these four
principles
of of and this notion of the people
build capacity faster than others and it
was
spiritual intellectual physical and
emotional i just saw that pattern and
actually
from our company's standpoint that's how
we had been training our employees not
not i mean yes there's direct training
to what they're related to but we had
tried
to we were training them to become
better overall and we were getting the
business benefit of that and they were
getting the benefit
outside of work it's odd to hear someone
in the business
sphere use the word spiritual i don't
yeah and i and
look i i struggled with that word i am
not very religious
i i tried to find 100 different words
that might
work for it because so spiritual
capacity is not religious
in my definition it is it is who you are
and what you want most
for most people i think it is being able
to identify their personal core values
because i think that ties to their
success
everywhere ties to their success with
their selves with their family with
their business and and like we work with
leaders in our organization to identify
their personal core values
so so that they can understand
themselves as a leader i think most
people that is just the
missing like rudder in their life in
terms of
getting the boat going in the right they
might have a really nice boat might be
going really fast and look pretty but it
is like
going to antarctica and they want to be
in hawaii
and so until they get to antarctica that
they realize that really doesn't make
them happy
[ __ ] i didn't mean to be here i've got
two two threads open in my mind first
one was greg mcewen author of
essentialism
on this show he told us a story about an
executive he worked with who
got to the top of a particular industry
very well known industry uh 25 years
he'd been working there
and found that when he made it he was vc
of something international corp um
multi-level story yeah yeah and uh he
found out that he he didn't have a he
couldn't talk to his son him and his son
had a very
strange relationship his son was 18 or
20 or something and he some wouldn't
speak to him
literally the relationship had just
devolved into nothingness
and he got to this peak that he thought
he was going to this destination this
antarctica
and then in greg's words he realized
that he'd won
the wrong game and that avoidance
of going incredibly fast in precisely
the opposite direction
and that is the other part which is a
mental model called
direction over speed that if you're
going in precisely the right direction
even very very slowly every day you're
making progress
conversely you can go incredibly fast
degrees and you're going i mean this is
what we learned with the parallel lines
and yeah
there's a slide i show in one of my
presentations on capacity building and
it has this beautiful house on a lake
right it's a similar thing and i say to
people you got to be if
if if this house is your goal you got to
be very honest with yourself about the
why
is the house to show yourself in the
world you made it right because
because then that might have one level
of satisfaction but if you say that it's
this
house that you have to have on the lake
for your families and generations
and in getting the house you lose your
kids and get divorced
you are not likely to reach your goals i
just don't think a lot of us
if it was really about family if family
was the why
then you should not sacrifice family in
the pursuit of that house you should
actually vacation with a family and
pick the land together and work on the
drawings together you should not go
isolate from yourself from your family
and make money so so i think that's
i came to understand at some point that
that long term the connection between
spiritual intellectual capacity so
intellectual capacity is like
your operating system how do you learn
plan goal set execute with discipline
in service of what you want your
long-term goals need to
fulfill one or more core values in order
for it to work
right you have to be working towards
something that actually
fulfills a core uh purpose or else it i
feel like you get to that hollow
that hollow ending very much so how do
people find their why then is that where
we start is that the beginning of the
the
mlt that we're we're going through the
service that we're going through
yeah the the uh look a lot of people now
this is a great time to think about it
the why is a whole more complicated
process i
i consider the why similar to the sort
of core purpose i think it's the topic
sentence i think that's
deep and requires a lot of work if you
figure out your core values
first to me those are the pillars like
if you can identify these are my full
these are the core principles i am i've
always been i've impacted why
sometimes the why starts to become
clearer because it is literally like the
the
roof or the topic sentence that sits
across these pillars of values
i always say for for a company the why
is easier because it's always usually
why they started right like we started
to eradicate blindness and then
they figure out the values as they get
team for a person i think you
you more want to be clear on the values
um and then the why is is hard work and
it ties to friday forward i wrote this
week i mean i will say 90
not 90. 70 of the time i think people's
why
is connected to a deep point of pain or
something
early from their childhood or experience
they had from which
in in a positive way becomes the driving
force for why they do what they do
i think it's very obvious for some
people i think for other people it's
sitting right there but it's amazing how
they haven't made the
like a couple times because i spent a
lot of time paying attention to this
i've asked people a question or pointed
it together
and you know and they look like suddenly
very shocked and vulnerable
versus some people are aware i was at
one of these dinners a while back and
there was one of these you know sketch
artists who
you know does the whole thing in real
time and
uh you know because i'm around this a
lot i was like this is an amazing skill
like how did you learn this and she said
my purpose is to help people see and be
heard that was her answer
and i was like you know like you hear
that out of one percent of
point one percent of a lot of people i
said can i ask you a question uh and you
don't have to answer it i always pray
again you don't want to does that
come from a very personal place for you
i i'd just love to know and she looked
at me and she's like
i had a significant stutter until i was
15 years old
so to me that was just like that is
that's a case study and i think for that
type of person it's clear
for a lot of us there's this mental
firewall in between
the experience and and and and and that
and
you know i think some people don't want
to be as a victim to me it's just your
story it's your truth
you know the example i think i used in
the book is like let's say you had a
single parent
who did their best for you and worked
three jobs and got you into college and
made you successful
but you were alone a lot after school
because of that
you might go on to form this
award-winning after-school education
program
like it's not it it's just your truth
your parent
you're not upset about your parent they
did the best but there was something in
that
that that you know you wanted to fix for
other people and in fact i actually
think that severe
drive comes is what is what's created
from that experience
it's so interesting what our childhood
experiences and the
predispositions and the presumptions
that we have about the world and
ourselves and
how we connect with others it's it
carries through and then it
keeps on rearing its head you know like
when you see uh
dolphins jumping out of the ocean you're
like it's flat and then every so often
it just jumps out
oh there's that thing again um steven
pressfield was on the show a couple of
weeks ago and he talks about shadow
careers have you heard him talk about
this
no okay so it sounds like it might tie
into what you're talking about there
that
a shadow career a lot of the time is
analogous to what someone
feels their true calling is but it's far
enough away that it protects them from
failing at the thing they love
super interesting so the examples that
he gave were
um people who always wanted to be actors
that go and become entertainment lawyers
so they are close to that you're going
to say they become like play coaches or
something like that but yeah
maybe i guess maybe that maybe the
director as well perhaps that they get
to
they get to do it but they don't um yeah
and they they get to look after
they do to the sort the deals it's
analogous they're kind of there but it's
a shadow career it's just a
it's the lesser version of of what they
genuinely wanted to be someone wanted to
be a
a singer on stage and then became a
teacher teaching music
and you're like well it you you almost
there but without the pressure and i
think that's
kind of related it's interesting and and
i think what we'll see coming out of
covet i mean
how many people you know like people get
comfortable and
you know in that comfort they are not
willing to leave okay
for better right so i think you know
they get laid off
and that shadow career becomes the
primary career it's oftentimes it takes
that i think covert 19 will be a huge
career transition for a lot of people
say look
you finally took away from me what i
wasn't willing to kill the sort of
comfortable
and now i'm gonna you know in the midst
of this without good options i'm gonna
lean
into that right and uh it's interesting
how that how that happens
do you think that we're going to see the
reversal of the polarity of this stuff
because i was talking to daniel sloss
netflix special comedian this week
and he said he thinks we've lost a whole
generation of creatives and artists
in all forms live musicians that have
realized they can't perform live
comedians that haven't been able to keep
their comedy going
artists that can't go and sell their
work to anyone cause no one's going to
art exhibitions
etc etc i wonder whether the people
who had um embraced their
proper calling they're full calling
perhaps may have had it they'll go the
other way
and go into shadow career and the people
for whom they were looking for this
opportunity
i wonder whether you're going to have
the entire store bar stool get turned
upside down
yeah you know there are always some
seismic and permanent changes in these
things but then i think there's always
an overestimation of things that will
never be the same
which you know isn't true i just think
you feel you see a ton of innovation
right i think you see
i remember watching this video of an
exercise person doing it in front of an
apartment building and everyone was out
on
italy i think yeah yeah so i i i
look i think the art i think everyone
will innovate i think it will be over
you know at some point people are
actually you know really
desperate for music and creative and
there'll be a ton of demand
um but but it's almost like there will
be some rotation right some of those
people might give up and get into
something else and then have a fear of
going back
but i think then you have those other
people we just talked about who might
actually dive into that because there's
no
risk now so i i continue to see
any business requires innovation i think
you'll see
new types of art or digital art or
outdoor art or
concerts and some of that stuff will
stick and people may you know you may
just be more outdoor
i'm surprised still someone hasn't
figured out how to do a massive socially
distanced con
concert you know on a so we had one we
had one
i i [ __ ] you not ten minutes
behind me yeah there was a thousand
person
music festival going on i know we're not
talking
uh like cream fields or coachella kind
of size
but it was um individual pens people
came in in zones um you had like a
fenced bit around you you and a group of
six in a bubble and there was service
going past
but live band live music stage shows
and people wanted i'm sure they were so
happy to have that right it was a big um
yeah exactly okay so core values in that
case if core values are going to inform
purpose
where do we start finding our core
values be some people listening perhaps
for whom
they are really questioning their
current life direction at the moment
they think
come on robert give me the give me the
red pill on core values yeah
it's it's it's not that easy to do i've
actually just finishing up a course on
it because the thing i get asked about
the most i
i put a couple resources and elevate
on this and questions you could ask but
it's a process
um that you go through and it it takes 6
to 12 months but you start it and i
think you start
with some questions and there's some
examples on there on you know thinking
about the types of scenarios with you've
been really ha
i'm going to paraphrase a complicated
process into simplicity sort of how it's
done
because i've done this with now a bunch
of different leaders and and it works
um but you ask a bunch of different
questions that
and you answer them for yourselves that
produce uh responses like
they're kind of best and worst and and
you you ask them a bunch of different
ways you create a bunch of different
lists and then you start looking across
the list for the themes because
where was i successful where was i not
what are the characteristics of people i
struggle with where do i not
you know one of the one of the and you
start thinking about those questions you
will start to notice patterns that will
illuminate your
core values you know one of the
questions that i always say that's the
101 the sort of 303
i don't know if you guys use that
numbering and college classes university
classes
have no idea what you're talking about
sorry so 101 is what we call entry level
university courses uh here so the the
advanced version
is if you want to sit down right now
right
what someone you would want someone to
say at your funeral for your eulogy
about you
and the impact that you had on their
life i did that exercise
long before i did the actual core value
work
and a lot of the terminology was in
there because when you get that raw
about what
how do you want to be remembered what do
you want people think of you it gets to
your values and the impact that you want
to make
um but you know i always say like the
analogy that i give with core values i
think we know our core value when it's
crossed
right and and that's a lot of us so
picture you're driving a really nice car
through a tunnel
the lights are off you hit the right
side wall it goes
you know all the stuff so you pull the
car off the wall and and you get in the
lane and then you hit the other wall
right this is kind of how we make
decisions we don't know what
it's like once we feel the it's crossed
we move away from
it but if that's a nice car you'd really
want the lights to be on
and the things to be painted and saying
i shouldn't get near that wall
and that wall is that job that person
that relationship because
because these are opposite values to
myself
i talk about the big three i think when
you think about you know where you
choose to live
who you choose to partner your vocation
or work if you
make those decisions not align with your
core values it's
very unlikely to work you can marry
someone or
partner with someone who's different
different hobbies interests whatever but
when you get to the hard stuff
if your values aren't aligned i think
that's the i don't think you're
it's not a clone it's clearly the
opposite's attract my wife and i are
very different in respect when we get to
the really hard difficult stuff we are
philosophically
um aligned on it so that's the
that that that's the basics i think you
can have decisions in front of you and
you should say i should do that i should
not do that
i've heard you say that physical fitness
physical well-being is one of your
core values what are the rest of them
yeah so so it's it's
i'll just run through them quickly that
oh one of my core values
yeah yeah yours my my so my core values
are
health and vitality so that includes
physical fitness so
uh find a better way and share it which
explains a lot of what i do
self-reliance uh one that i came up with
that really is fitting but it took me a
while to get the right word which is
respectful authenticity
and then the last is long-term
orientation so if i pick
some activity that is aligned to all of
those or if i pick a parental activity
like i am so happy and i'm doing well
if i do something that is crosses a lot
of those then
uh not so well so when you think about
those first two like find a better way
at health and vitality right
every year i pick a fitness challenge or
something new for me to do because
i haven't done it it's better way and
then it forces me to train and
you know be healthy and and that's
important and so we talked about what
was this years
this year's is a half marathon which i'm
is i'm gonna have to do
social virtually yes but i'm working up
towards that
distance um i've biked from london to
paris two years ago with a group i've uh
done olympic triathlon i've just bunch
of different
uh stuff but um it's interesting like
when we talk to our kids around
you know we have family core values too
and when we talk to them around
like not having a third cookie you know
it is under the value of
because we talk about being healthy and
that's not healthy it's not a rule it's
a
it aligns to a value are you familiar
with ben bergeron
from the no crossfit world you would
really really enjoy his work so
yeah maybe i yeah he's the ex-coach of
matt fraser fitness man on the planet
uh he has a podcast called chasing
excellence which he's named after his
book
and um i would highly you and him sing
very much from the same hymn sheet
especially with regards to the family
values thing
everything that he does is driven from
his values uh i think that's great i i
spent a lot of time this year working on
my core values and
it's really informed a lot of my
direction
um it's helped me to lean into
discomfort in projects because i know
that it is truly aligned with the things
that i do as opposed to previously
especially if you suffer with imposter
syndrome which we all which all
successful people do you know people
who've gotten there for the wrong
reasons don't seem to have it right
yeah we also we really who are lucky
never have imposter syndrome it's
interesting people work hard
i'll i'll take that as a compliment in
that case um yeah so
it's really really helped so everyone
that's listening if you haven't gone
away and done that
um get yourself a copy of elevate
otherwise chris sparks
he has an experiment without limits and
there's some great work worksheets in
that
taylor pearson also has some great
worksheets um some good ways to do it so
we've we've
spoken about the spiritual should we go
into the intellectual next do those two
kind of follow on from each other yeah
they actually go in a particular order
uh for me so let me just let me set the
framework and then we can dive in each
one just to make i'll recast so
spiritual is your core values
kind of you know who you are and what
you won't want
intellectual capacity as i always say
it's about how you improve your ability
to think learn
plan execute with discipline so this is
kind of growth mindset being proactive
long-term goals short-term goals routine
habits accountability it's kind of
once you know what you want how do you
get it your operating system how do you
make your operating system better
then physical capacity kind of what it
sounds you know health well-being
physical performance
resilience kind of embracing competition
really
now i know now i know what i want i know
i want to get it and now i'm motivated
to
you know keep myself in good shape uh to
get there
and then emotional the last one it's
interesting the hardest one for a lot of
people this is the world around you so
it's how do you react to challenging
situations your emotional mindset and
the quality of your relationships
so my analogy is that if if spiritual
capacity was designing the race car
uh you know intellectual capacity was
building it physical was sort of testing
it on test track
emotional is like how do you do in that
car when it's out on the road with
the rain and sun and lots of other cars
right some cars will
do better than their spec and some will
do a lot worse so
emotional capacity is really interaction
with with the world around us and the
things that we don't control
based on your time coaching and also
working within your business
which of those four areas do you find
people falling short or tripping over
the most
i most so it's interesting like for me
i i fall in and out of uh them you know
physical and
physical can be a real gateway if you
get tired and cranky think about it you
lose sight of your goals
you don't interplay well with other
people you know it
you kind of give up your learning and
you're thinking a lot of that stuff
i i for most people i think they haven't
even touched
the spiritual capacity part and and so
the most important thing that they can
do is start the work there
that's the one for me that once you get
it 90 right you're pretty good it
doesn't require
daily maintenance as much because the
other ones
align you to it right you say oh i know
my value so i need this is what i need
to go and learn and do
but i so i i would say that i think that
that's the one that people haven't
touched
i think a lot of people struggle the
most with emotional capacity
particularly right now in terms of when
they know what they want they're still
haven't moved away from people who
aren't aligned to that
or they really mix things that they
control
and that they don't control right so
perfect example
you and i get into a car accident you
know this morning
um i you know you you uh are
are enlightened and so you're like oh
i've got insurance that could have been
worse
you walk away you go you go do three
podcast interviews you have a great day
you meet a bunch of friends all this
stuff
you know i'm like swearing all the
freaking chris and one more thing in the
world that what could go wrong this year
and i i get in a fight with my brother
i don't do the goal thing that i said i
want to do like we both experienced the
same
thing right how we chose to respond and
react to that we tell ourselves
different truth we tell ourselves the
truth that
my day got ruined by a car accident well
that's not that's not really the whole
truth the truth is you had a car
accident and that wasn't your fault
but you control what comes after that
it's interesting that you haven't
mentioned there or at least i said
what some of the hurdles people overcome
you mentioned that
a lot of the time we vacillate between
many of them
but intellectual wasn't one of the ones
at least that came to the forefront of
your mind
i think i've got a potential hypothesis
about why that might be the case
i think that increasingly
solutions to problems in a post-modern
enlightenment non-religious world are
very cerebral
we have this huge proliferation of
personal development self-development
and
rightly so you know i'm contributing to
it now we put
three four five hours of personal
development content out every single
week
yeah i think a lot of the time that
causes people to
to look for a very cerebral very
cognitive
um very transactional solution okay i
have a problem with my this thing
like which page in atomic habits is it
that i need to turn to to like find
the particular habit that i'm doing to
do the whatever thing or like
you know you know i mean it's that's how
i think that a lot of people are looking
to get the solution
whereas what you've identified there is
it's all of the ancillary stuff that
actually feeds in
to our ability to get that engine to be
bigger to get the fuel efficiency to be
faster to get the
uh steering to be tighter right and and
it's an it's an interesting point you
make because i think that a lot of
people in that realm and
like are again they're looking for that
hack or that quick fix
that's not what it's meant to mean it
meant to me anyone once i know what my
most important contribution is
i'm going to do everything i can to
learn
and and focus and be disciplined about
going in that direction it is
it is the glue that sort of holds you to
that it's not the
it's not the quick fix right i'm not i i
think there's a misunderstood line
between the 80 20 rule and hacks
you know i i think that i i think
there's always an 80 20 rule
there was just some study i saw
yesterday someone sent me because they
know i love the 80 20 rule that like
20 of super spreaders or 19.8 percent of
super spreaders in
singapore had created 80 of the cases
like it was just really
it was really easy to give you another
one to add to your collection yeah
so the bottom 80
of men on tinder are competing for the
bottom
20 of women and the top 80 of women on
tinder are competing for the top
20 of men sounds about right that's from
datonomics so there you go
facts don't care about your feelings
karen i'm very sorry about that um
intellectual how do we talk about
expanding our intellectual capacity what
are some of the
the key areas that you um find coming up
during your work
to do with that yeah so to a lot of its
goal setting and i think understanding
i was not i didn't understand this you
know i would set a lot of one year goals
and i would meet them and i'd feel great
but they weren't
connected so to me it's now a reverse
engineering process what are the
long-term goals do the long-term goals
fulfill
the values and therefore short-term
goals are actually down payments on the
long-term goals or else we go for the
short stuff
versus like i need to make deposits when
you have two things and one of them is
put the envelope
in the mail or the other is climb the
mountain like we just put the envelope
in the mail we put the envelope in the
mail and the mountain
stays pretty far rather than take a step
take a step take a step so i
i think it's i think i'll give i'll
answer this on giving you
examples at both ends of the spectrum so
really setting what we want why we want
it
and then committing to the pieces to get
there again back to that house like i
want this house intent well
i need to save the money for it my
family and i need to go to towns find
out where we want it to be we need to
pick a
develop like those are all things i
could do over time rather than just
you know deciding get there and then the
other
fully through the whole spectrum on the
other side of routine all that stuff i
think is just accountability right
great people and leaders they want
accountability
other people do not you know i was
hearing someone reinforce that like
world
todd herman world-class performance
coach and he was saying like michael
jordan
they love accountability they love being
yelled at told they're not doing
something you know average people
do not want accountability they want to
excuse their way out of it so
there's multiple levels of that you know
their self-accountability which is can
be journal writing it's really annoying
to write you're going to do something
for five days in a row
and read it you know and then do it
there's there's peer accountability
where even me sending you
what i said i was gonna do that week
every friday at 10 a.m you know upset up
and that's where a lot of mastermind
groups come in and then
there's public accountability where
people just put their thing out at the
beginning of the year dear world
this is how much i'm gonna weigh at the
end of the year this is what i'm gonna
do
anyone who does all three is is probably
in a unique
rarified feel i like it where else in
intellectual do people have holes that
can quite easily be filled
i yeah i i think there is confusion
between an intellectual capacity is not
doing more right it is actually
think about upgrading the processor when
you upgrade the processor it should
crunch more data with less energy
right so i think a lot of times like
let's say i a lot of people this crosses
into emotional i struggle with
difficult conversations at work like i
really struggle with them performance
conversation
so the night before i sweat i don't
sleep i get all without
or i just sit down for a day and i read
three books
you know i listen to patty mccord's
podcast who's or kim scott or like the
world leaders on
different conversations and i now have
upgraded my operating system with the
tools and tactics
where actually doing this now is less
work and less energy that to me is a
huge mistake i am not advocating anyone
run the hamster wheel faster
i am saying upgrade the processor so the
task requires
less work and less energy i love that i
think action
is the antidote to anxiety comes in
quite well there yeah
much of the time when we have anxiety
about
anything which is approaching us in the
future it's because of a fear of a lack
of capacity in order to be able to deal
with it yeah
and then that's where procrastination
comes you think oh
i'm really going to struggle with that
thing that project that conversation i'm
going to have and then
the deadline arrives i'll put it off
i'll
find an excuse i'll do it tomorrow i'll
delegate it to someone else whatever it
might be
whereas as you've identified there if
you're moving towards
that goal right you're in control people
solve these problems i i mean
i interviewed patty mccord from netflix
who's you know really
kind of thought leader on the great
culture but direct with people and
when she we talked about like letting
people go and something they really
struggled with you know she
she would coach her mentees when they
had to have one of these conversations
they haven't done it she's like
call your voicemail have the
conversation with your voicemail
five times before you do it and listen
to it right
there was not a secret it wasn't a hack
it was actually
practicing it doing it like knowing the
framework how to do it and
it was very pragmatic advice on like
yeah of course you're not gonna be good
at this you've never had this
conversation that's why
you need to practice having this
conversation i wonder again whether this
links back to
the cerebral overly cognitive argument
that i made a little bit earlier
that we presume because we see wonderful
leaders that we
guess are just bestowed with this
magnetism
and they just flow in a room and
everyone loves them
it almost makes us forget that it's a
skill the same as anything else great
it's a great lie we tell ourselves a lot
of the stories on friday ford
do you missed it if you've ever listened
to how i built this podcast you know my
favorite part is
all these super successful company and
people their worst
dark moment where like they were almost
out of business and and they go on for a
long time you know for a lot of people
we love to be like oh that company was
an overnight success
right because that ascribes it to timing
or luck or i don't think professional
athletes get enough credit you know in
cases where you stay
just so gifted like practice is 10 hours
a day like if you want to be a
professional speaker and you practice
speaking 10 hours a day
you're probably a good speaker i mean
most of these athletes look it's what
they love to do
but they the amount of work that they
put in to practice things before they do
them
far exceeds anyone in the business world
100
i've been hugely on this flex recently
that so
few people even if you're fully aligned
your goals your dreams what you know you
need to do you've broken it down into
the individual steps and you're
committing yourself fully
being as present as you can but think
about how far
from an athlete's level of preparation
everybody else's
except for the the total freaks within
their industry the elon musk's of this
world probably a couple of guys at
google and facebook you know
you think an athlete's optimizing his
food his rest
he's throwing about he has three coaches
and he's the best in the world and
he's surrounded by a team of people who
are all on the same journey as him
he's sleeping thinking about what he's
going to do tomorrow he's waking up in
the morning at the time that's
prescribed
all of that stuff so thinking like an
athlete
no matter what your industry is i i've
taken a lot of inspiration from that
this year
trying to turn pro right and who are the
athletes that always disappoint that
people are
or you know regret signing they're the
ones
who don't do that work who looked like
right but they had a lot of talent right
but they looked from the outside coming
in the best signing of the year
and then you get him into the training
pitch and he's leaving
halfway through the day they they they
when i think about all that bus and
national football league which was the
biggest draft it's
it was the really talent they were
drooling at a
talent but not passion and wasn't
willing to do the work
right what's next physical
physical yeah physical how do we expand
our physical capacity
well it's interesting you know physical
taking physical as an analogy to the
other capacities we understand it more
we tend to think that we have these
things or we don't have these things
right versus you wouldn't say oh i can
lift a found weight five times or i
can't you'd say if i did it for
90 days each day then it would be it
would be easier so
um you know it's the health well-being
physical performance
uh i think we've moved past the uh greg
mckeown talks about this a lot but i
think we've actually fortunately moved
past
celebrating leaders and executives who
get no sleep and and i think actually
people are now
yeah they're now going the other way
saying i sleep nine hours a night we're
not we're not celebrating that anymore
um i think there's managing stress and
and this is again we're
we're where we build resilience i think
sometimes i'm actually
i believe i think resilience is this
emotional and physical
flywheel so i think we we do something
and i had a couple conversations with
performance experts around this because
i was like what's the chicken and what's
the egg and
the consensus not by a 80 20 but by a 60
40 was that
i i think you do something hard that you
don't think that you can do
upon doing that you gain
emotional confidence that lets you be
willing to set a next benchmark but it's
actually that effort i don't think you
can will yourself to resilience like
think
you actually have to get through that
race take that extra step do it and then
you're like
oh what other lies have i been telling
myself
and you know the the thing that people
are pointing out is that
there's a mentor of mine he's great
speaker he always offers in a speech ten
thousand dollars to anyone who goes back
and brings a can of stress into the
meeting
um he goes go go go find me a can of
stress and and i will pay you
and his point is that stress is not an
external thing it is
actually an internal response that we do
to ourselves and
you could be stressed about you know the
deal you're about to close for signing
your company for a billion dollars you
can be stressed about
you know not having enough food this day
your job it actually has the same
physical response on your body we are
using a
very outdated flight or fight-or-flight
mechanism
like all the time which was meant to
save our life and it does
biological stuff to our body that's like
pretty unhealthy
so if if we sit in that state
we we are re releasing tons of cortisol
like if we don't
but it but it is with we are the only
ones that can get us out of that state
right i mean it is
the world does things that that cause
stress to us but as we said before
that is a different threshold point for
everyone it's a different subject matter
for everyone but it
it shows up physiologically the same so
you've got something's occurred you've
had a phone call
something really stressful is about to
happen the partnership that you thought
was about to go through tomorrow
the merger is on the rocks what would
you prescribe to someone
who has had that call to get themselves
out of that stress response
and to allow them to have that clarity
of thought again uh i mean
the basic thing is probably to get
outside you know i
you actually have built up that cortisol
which was
some actually talking to someone about
this who understands the science of it
more so you've actually built
up the fight or flight thing and so you
need to fight or flight
right so if you actually let off that
steam level yeah if you got into a big
fight you would probably
let it off okay okay so go put someone
in the street probably go for a run
or uh interval training or something to
actually like
i am very cognizant i don't like running
but i love how i feel after i run
so i listen to podcasts or i do whatever
i can because i know
that it just puts me physically in a
state that
that i need to be in but yeah you
actually need to go blow
off that steam i think literally or
figuratively yes
breathing as well i'm going to guess
focusing on deeper breathing activating
the parasympathetic nervous system
yeah look if you look there's a whole
range of things i think
uh if if if if you do you know a
meditation
if you do these things and you're
comfortable these are all things that
you could do it just i guess it goes to
the level of where the person
is it's a good time to turn on your com
or headspace app
i actually think some people though in
that immediate thing
aren't able to transition right into
that like
in fact i'd say like let's say this was
at 10 a.m
you probably want to blow off some steam
literally
but you know i what i found on those
days is actually the meditation or
something else would be really important
in the afternoon
to make sure that my night's sleep was
good later on right that i'm not it's
not
replaying but it is it is hard to move
it takes probably you know a dalai lama
type person to move from
severe stress straight to meditation
unless they have deep
practice in that anyone who's tried to
do that all that you do
is sit in the same lovely meditation
pose
yeah and then you just ruminate about
the thing that you're worried about and
you're like this is when you get mad at
yourself that you can't
waste any time yeah so again i'm not a
scientist about
anything but i but i i do think you need
some sort of
you know walking breathing relief valve
from that
um but look if you have it out with the
person you might you might have actually
already had that i think it's more if
you go away stewing
that yeah i get it where else in
physical we've had sleep and stress
two key areas what else um yeah i think
i think
you know exercise eating i am i am not
a a dietitian i am not you know so i
but i i've read what i try to do is read
from everyone that's smarter
and and take all the intersecting things
and what do i think is the
is the principle so one thing is i i
think there's a lot of science now
that that there's a lot of brain and
body
connection right between what we eat and
that it crosses the gut level and that
affects how we feel or otherwise
i think the also dangerous thing out
there is that there's a lot of people
saying that whatever
their diet is whether it's gluten or
paleo or this
is the thing that everyone should do and
the really smart people who know this
will say that it's completely the
opposite you know one
one man's poison is another man's uh um
now for now i'm pulling the allergies uh
yeah we'll go with the british
tonic so um i think
you know there are definitely different
things that that affect each of our
health and make us feel
and i think you need to figure out what
works for you but in general
you know less sugar less processed food
less alcohol less caffeine like i think
those are probably all
general principles many of us are on a
you know upper in the morning
down or on the in the evening plan and i
what i what i understand from again the
people who understand this i'm i'm very
honest that this is second hand is that
you're you know you're not allowing your
body to go through those processes
organically if you're always creating
them
artificially right so if you to the
example before if you're
only can calm down by having a drink
you've now trained and you can only get
yourself awake by having a coffee you
are now training
your body to to do that it's weakening
very much
so the buttress the scaffolding that
your body's laid upon you know like one
of those
is it the dolly painting where all of
the clocks are melting
and they're all really sort of flaccid
all the clocks are melting on the side
of
a cupboard and it's like propped up by
loads of different individual prongs
like you know when you put your hands in
pizza though and it's all falling all
over it's like these are the little
prongs however if you take them away and
you
allow yourself to cultivate those
capacities naturally innately
if you choose to have a drink a coffee
then you get to expand your domain of
competence on top of something which is
already sufficient
as opposed to um ideally you'd have to
drink after the run
and the coffee after the workout right
where you've you've combined
in the organic response yeah i get it so
emotional final one yeah this tricky one
so i you know a big there's two big
things of emotional there's a bunch of
different things but the buckets
how you react to the things that you
don't control um
so that's the first one and then
relationships both the quality of your
relationships and who you choose to
spend time with
in the first one i think it's
interesting like i i have some family
members that spend a lot of time on
weather apps and it always frustrates me
i'm like to me the weather
the weather is the perfect emotional
capacity like
the weather is going to be the weather
right you are not going to change it
but if you're constantly oh it's going
to rain tomorrow all right do you look
and it's going to rain tomorrow and like
oh i'm gonna go to the movies and get an
umbrella or do you actually like
get stressed about what the weather is
you get frustrated that it's not
lining up to what you wanted right that
is a kind of a
microcosm of emotional capacity you
don't control it
how do you react to it and the second is
relationships i think you know
we spend a lot of time with people who i
would use a term called energy vampires
like where you actually feel
worse after spending time with them uh
probably not as much time like
you and i might not might see each other
once a year but we have this
awesome uplifting conversation it's
forward moving whatever
but then i'm spending a lot of time with
a friend that i just don't have the
you know courage to that i literally
feel worse every time
um you know i spend with them and i i
actually think we need to reallocate
you know jim rome said you are the
average of the people you spend the five
people you spend the most time with i i
think we need to
even make a list of who who do we need
and want to spend more time with and how
without breaking up or blowing up with
those people do we remove
energy from those relationships and an
example someone gave me is like
don't say stuff you don't mean like we
should have lunch again next week like
after you just got like you don't you
just got through lunch and you're
terrible and this person complained
about the thing over again like we
should do that again soon
you don't have to say that you don't you
don't have to call someone and have the
same conversation
you know with that relative every four
days you could call them
every six days um so this thing about
energy vampires really like if
you people you feel worse with after
spending time with
you need to figure out a way to spend
less time with those people they are not
moving you towards your spiritual and
intellectual capacity in any way
the british equivalent of a energy
vampire is a mood hoover
yeah you guys are so passive aggressive
oh it's so funny you'll have a hard time
you'll be like no
let's definitely get lunch next week and
then afterwards like oh my god that
person is the worst like
yeah i think there's certain things that
both americans and british
could take from each other and you you
are correct
the um the passive aggressiveness the
quiet behind to the back
sulking very sulky very silky nation
with someone in our industry with a
bunch of competitors and they walked up
and hugged all of them and
uh you know walked away i was like that
is so nice we wouldn't do that neil so
you guys all get along like we all hate
each other
i thought it was so it was so
stereotypical
okay so we've looked at the relationship
side of emotional what's left
uh yeah i think it's the things that we
control so
so circumstances uh and then and then
and then people
and and i think there's also a piece
that against a resilience there is that
emotional side of resilience like
how do i you know how do i plan for the
next thing i'm gonna do that i didn't
think that i could physically do because
what what i think keeps people moving
forward in that is
is being vulnerable is getting out of
their comfort zone you know i think that
greatly increases their emotional
capacity people want to share
people want to be vulnerable they're
just scared to
and when they do the depth of their
relationship you know two people have
been having this superficial
conversation
for five years aren't talking about the
real thing that they want to talk about
that would actually create
the bond that they're seeking massively
a huge problem amongst young guys i
think especially
ones that are professionals type a's
trying to be overachievers
they and i did for a very long time i
presumed
that strength and confidence and bravado
and courage and
all of these things went along with not
showing vulnerability
whereas quite the opposite is true that
the people with whom i have the deepest
relationships
are the ones that i've been the most
vulnerable with and it becomes
self-fulfilling
when you tell someone something which in
the wrong hands could be quite
catastrophic
to you yeah that's really where you make
a connection and
i think there's a book that's
up on the big shelf up there the lonely
century by noreena hurts uh
talking about this loneliness epidemic
that we've got at the moment and i
wonder how many people are combatting
loneliness by trying to be
overly confident by thinking i am going
to be the sort of friend that other
people would want to be friends with
and the truth is that being more
vulnerable and showing that side of you
that is precisely the opposite of what
you think other people want
might be the quickest way to make a
connection i think there's like there's
a lot of culture in this
there's a lot of gender history in this
particularly with boys
you know feelings i i mean i i've heard
the story you know closer to home for
you i can't tell you how many times i've
heard a story from a coach or a speaker
an irish boy you know and his father who
just wanted to
have a real discussion and give him a
hug and i mean my
friend phil mckernan you know just talks
about you know he wasn't it wasn't until
he was 45 that he and his dad said they
loved it too each other they were
you know just it was this thing you
didn't do and they danced around it and
it was like as a
as his son that's all he wanted you know
what and
and i just i feel like i've heard so
there is a lot of there are cultural
implications
in in a lot of this stuff but i do think
generationally it's
it's changing a bit which is nice i
really like
the analogy that you drew between using
the weather app
so we've had a lot of stoics on recently
including ryan holiday and the weather's
a good example
using the weather as look controllables
versus uncontrollables the dichotomy of
control all this sort of stuff
but thinking about the fact that i was
laughing at how
your friends who like to look at the
weather app because i'm like oh
ridiculous why would you do that
but really everything on your phone is
the weather app apart from individual
messages
looking news is the weather precisely
you're watching that watching the
presidential debate
do you think that what you say is going
to change what
donald trump or joe biden says the next
time it
it affects you and and hopefully my mom
won't listen to this but my mom was in a
tizzy the other night and i was talking
to her and
you know upset more normal about what's
going on i was like and she just had
surgery so she's i know she's had sit
there i'm like
how long have you watched the news today
was the first thing i said i was like
like well i just i'm like turn it off
just turn it off
you've overdosed on news today mom i can
tell the two things i've been able to
tell in covid when people are in
bad places are are and usually it's
probably
both one they've been consuming too much
news
you know and and and two they have not
gotten enough sleep those seem to be
very clear markers of sort of just low
ability to deal that's a one-way ticket
to feeling pretty miserable in 2020 i
think news
too much news not enough sleep and
that's why i believe in these buffers
like
i leave my phone downstairs i don't
really think this guy texting me
you know this morning asking me
something about podcast this afternoon
did you get i'm like i'm sorry i don't
look at my phone
for the first hour in the day and i
leave it downstairs because nothing good
happened overnight you know other than
some guy emailing me that there's some
guy who you know
11 million pounds state and i'm the you
know beneficiary you know
i just sent him a check like nothing
great happens overnight
uh and and i'm not a doctor so it's not
an emergency but if i
as soon as i look at that i'm gonna be
pulled into that world
100 i've i mentioned before we started
i'm a club promoter and i have a
a little quip that i don't really
nothing good happens overnight
dude after 1am nothing nothing
interesting has
ever happened ever ever ever ever
happened
a bad email yeah precisely self-limiting
beliefs was something that i wanted to
talk about with
you a lot of people we mentioned
imposter syndrome
earlier on how can people overcome those
self-limiting beliefs
i i think you need to look at the source
of them i i think a lot of times
i think you can think back to childhood
there are a lot of things placed on
people and think about
where that came from also they're
stories that we tell ourselves because
we don't want to do something and we
don't want to fail at it like i always
think it's interesting when someone says
you know there's a framework that that a
coach i worked with once used more
business coach but someone says i can't
do that
i could never write a book okay well why
give me the five why's why you can't run
a book so his thing is he takes the five
reasons why you can't
do it and then ask you how you could
solve each of those five things well i
don't have the time
well how could you solve that well i
could you know i spend 30 minutes every
morning
writing it well i don't have the
experience well how could you solve that
well i could hire one of these companies
that does
you know ghostwriting well i don't have
a topic why do you solve that well i
could spend a few of those days in 30
minutes like
picking topics and asked my friend so
like it basically
like rhetorically puts it back on
themselves because
i i sometimes again we were told we
couldn't do something and the most
damaging ones come from third parties
but a lot of time i think it is a
protection mechanism
um look there's some reality like i
could not be a professional
football player like i don't have the
talent
i could work as hard as i want but on
the talent but but i just
i i i always score them when someone
tells me they can't do something that i
intuitively know that they can do
because i think they're just trying to
protect themselves
the alternative saying i don't want to
do that doesn't sound as good
i agree about internalizing the the bad
third-party
rhetoric yeah every bad inner voice that
we have
was once a bad out of voice i think yeah
someone told you you were stupid your
whole life like that's a very
hard thing to overcome and believe
you're smart right or someone said that
to you or
those things are pretty pretty damaging
it can also going back to what we said
at the very beginning talking
about the spiritual a lot of the time
people i think can internalize that and
use that as
the main thrust of their career so
there's another greg mcewen example
about a guy that was a
a cfo i think or a co or something but
still believed that he was terrible at
maths
because his like some grade school
primary school teacher
had said you suck at maths at eight
years old and he carried that with him
and then made it his career and still
ceo or cfo of this huge company
still believed that he couldn't do maths
and look i'm very
believing remember my respectful
authenticity value i i believe in
telling people the truth but i think as
as a manager a leader you can do
decades of damage right so if you worked
here and i was like chris you're just
not
take some right out of the office you're
just not management material right
it's like i that could sit with you for
a long time you could be really like
have some you know confidence issues
from that but if i sat down and said
chris you know
i've looked at you i've what you've done
managing you seem to
love being an individual contributor you
know you
you want to sell your own thing you want
to be responsible like that's very
different than leading a team i think
you could actually do really well in
this but
but this requires leading a team and i
don't really think that's actually what
you want to do
or whatever like those are very
different ways where one might actually
help you realize that
oh people i just thought i had to lead a
team to get ahead that's actually not
what i like and i've been doing it
versus me
crushing your soul by by attacking you
you know personally and i've heard from
a lot of people that how a comment from
my boss has
has had five or ten years of damage you
know on their on their confidence in
their career
it's dangerous man as you rise up
through the ranks of
any business and you start to get
subordinates below you or if you're a
business owner and you have the entire
company below you
the words that you say have a
disproportionate impact on people
long after you've left them or they've
left you
i do think there's a big um a lot of
responsibility
in that yeah i don't often hear talked
about actually either in
in the business no and the truth is the
truth right so to say chris you are not
doing well as a manager that is the
truth right but then the other
truth is and i think it's because you
actually don't want to be one if you
thought about it and you want to be
you don't want to manage salespeople you
want your 2 million book of business you
want the credit
that's great but you actually just need
a role that that reinforces that right
there are two different ways to have
that have that conversation
i love it final thing um you talk a lot
about how we can use and relate to our
competition
i think in 21st century always on social
media
comparisons how much do you earn yeah
the new house the new car
how can we use and relate to our
competition yeah to me
like healthy competition is is i
actually think we need to lose do
we need we need to learn to win well and
lose well and look all monopolies happen
because there's no competition
so i i actually believe that competition
is just about raising our own standards
and understanding that
whatever i'm doing today if i'm doing
the same thing in 10 years
it's probably not a winning strategy
right i like to say
if you were the best horse and buggy
repair person in the entire world you
probably don't have a lot of work right
now
so um i to me it's it's raising the bar
on yourself embracing it i'm not i i'm
not
i'm pro competition in that way i'm not
all saying it's all about winning i
actually
i don't believe in that at all but i
think when you elevate the playing field
you
you do it for everyone like i don't want
to be the ten thousands best place to
work like i
wanna be the you know top ten best
places to work i
i don't think you'd have a lot of people
who'd say like oh i want you know the
person i want to fill this role is the
person that
no one wanted right you know there's
usually someone that everyone's trying
to do so
my my and my favorite example is the
most enlightened yoga teacher in the
world
will compete for a single job at the
biggest you know most prestigious yoga
studio like
it just is is reality and there's times
when we need to win well and there's
times that we need to learn well
lose well but at least we're trying to
up our game i like it
robert man i really enjoyed today where
can people go if they want to sign up to
your newsletter where else do you want
to send them
uh yeah so everything's really
integrated now at robertglazer.com
glazeer.com uh the books there
books are there elevate podcasts there
and they can sign up for the friday ford
newsletter as well awesome man thank you
so much for today all right
you